Continuing in al-wajeez
in the chapter in the book of
purification, the chapter regarding
the
sunan of al-fitra.
We mentioned
the
narration that tells us about five
things that are of the fitra. Also,
another narration that mentions 10
altogether. Both of the narrations
are in Bukhari Muslim.
And
then the author went into some detail.
The first one that he mentions in detail
is al-khitan, which is circumcision, and
we discussed that in detail yesterday.
The next that the author goes into is
i'fa'ul lihya, growing out the beard.
Growing out the beard.
[Silence]
The author tells us that growing a
person's beard
is obligatory and completely shaving it
off, shaving it.
Halp means to shave it off with a razor
entirely. This is haram and this is
agreed upon amongst the four madhahib.
This is agreed upon amongst the fuqaha.
That shaving the beard is positively
prohibited and growing the beard is
obligatory. Where does the difference of
opinion come in?
The length of growth, what is considered
to be shaving it, what are the
parameters of the beard, are the cheeks
part of the beard, is under the jawline
part of the beard, etc. These are the
details that the fuqaha
discuss and debate.
He says, "And in shaving a a man shaving
his beard deliberately,
there is an element of imitation of
women in this practice."
And that is correct. Many of the fuqaha
have drawn that comparison and
mentioned this as a ruling. He says,
"And the messenger of Allah sallallahu
alayhi wasallam has cursed the men who
imitate the women and the women who
imitate the men." The beard in general,
in general, if we were to look at the
majority of humanity,
we would say that
the beard is something specific to men
and not having a beard is something very
specific to women in many cases, right?
But deliberately going out of your way
to shave your beard off completely and
entirely. This is something which
the scholars have agreed is
impermissible.
And
The author then says
[Silence]
He says, "And the Prophet Sallallahu
alaihi wasallam commanded in a number of
narrations that a man grow his beard or
lengthen his beard or allow his beard to
grow, and the nature of a command is
that it is obligatory, right?" And
that's not just in the Quran and Sunnah,
but in general in general life, when a
superior
commands an in an inferior or a
subordinate,
okay?
That articulates obligation, that that's
binding. It's not a suggestion.
For instance,
you say to your child, "Get me a glass
of water.
Go do this, clean your room, whatever it
is."
Is this
something which is optional?
Do you have to say, "This is binding
upon you. This is wajib.
Get me a glass of water."
No.
It is understood
that this is not optional.
And it is understood
that this is something which is
expected to be fulfilled as immediately
as received. As immediately as the
command is received, this is when it
is expected to be fulfilled.
And
many, if not most of the Uṣūliyyīn, view
that commands in the Quran and Sunnah
articulate obligation
unless otherwise specified.
Unless exempted. Anytime Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala or his messenger say,
"Do." It means that this is obligatory.
"Do not do." This is prohibited. Unless
there is some evidence
that exempts this command from being
obligatory. We say this is preferred,
this is mustahabb, this is strongly
suggested, this is strongly urged, or
if there is an evidence to prove
that this particular thing is exempt
from that general rule.
If we establish that, the author
mentions to us the narration of Abu
Hurairah
in which the messenger of Allah
sallallahu alayhi wasallam says, "Juzzu
[Arabic recitation]
Wal hadithu inda Muslim.
Yaqulu an ibn Umar radiyallahu anhu
ma'an an nabiyyi sallallahu alayhi
wasallam qala, "Khaliful mushrikin,
[Arabic recitation]
hadithu indal Bukhari wa Muslim. He
mentions the narration of Abu Hurairah
and
the narration of ibn Umar.
They both narrate that the messenger of
Allah sallallahu alayhi wasallam said,
"Cut down the mustache and
and
grow the beard
and do so to deliberately
differentiate yourselves from the
Magians al-Majus. Al-Majus are
Persian fire worshipers in the prophet
was salaam's time. And in the narration
of Omar the prophet was salaam was
salaam says
deliberately
differentiate yourselves from the
idolaters.
Grow out your beards and
trim
your mustaches. And here in this
narration he says what
meaning and cut down the mustache. This
narration is in Bukhari and Muslim. Now
I want you to notice something here.
Here the prophet
was salaam
mentions that growing the beard
trimming the mustache
this is in order to differentiate
himself the Muslim to differentiate
himself
from the Magians to differentiate
ourselves from the idolaters.
So does this mean if the idolaters start
to grow their beard and trim their
mustache
we should then start to grow our
mustache and trim our and and cut off
our beards?
Why not?
Now we all look the same.
[Arabic recitation]
they don't belong
a cleaner answer which is correct in
general, and that is that these are
sunan al-fitra.
This is the fitra.
Right? Remember the chapter, sunan
al-fitra?
Which means that that's not the driving
force
behind growing the beard and trimming
the mustache is just to differentiate
ourselves from other groups of
disbelievers. That isn't intended, and
that's important, and that may have been
very relevant in his time, but if those
things were to change, it still remains
to be part of al-fitra.
Just the same if
the mushrikin and the majus started to
pluck their armpit hair, do we start to
grow ours out? Do we start to braid ours
to make sure that we differentiate
ourselves from them?
What about if they start to circumcise
themselves and their children? Do we
uncircumcise our kids?
what about if they start to brush
their teeth regularly, we see
today? Should we stop brushing our
teeth? These are parts of al-fitra.
Which means that ideally all of humanity
should be doing this. Right? That is the
natural disposition. This is the natural
way Allah created the human being to
have these practices at every time and
every place.
An added benefit during his time is that
the majus and the mushrikin,
they had
flipped it.
They would grow out the mustache very
often and trim and and completely cut
off the beard.
And so the prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam said
in another narration
that one of the one of the things that
you know, we grow our beards for is in
order to differentiate ourselves from
the mushrikin, from the majus. But, this
is not the only singular driving force
behind this practice, right?
Remind me tomorrow, inshallah,
[Arabic recitation]
remind me to discuss the parameters of
the beard. What is considered part of
the beard and what isn't. We We ran out
of time.